this has been a real treat for me was a
seriously I adore you and I'm so happy
that you could come in and talk to us
and I just want to make sure that people
also check out Fleischmann because it's
really good and I love you know
obviously things are unfolding I've seen
three but I love that because of the
different choices you've made you've
found a way where you can be funny and
use that superpower but also be real and
bring people in it's that's a rare thing
so it's very kind thank you and I never
say like something is really good and I
think it's really good and yes we're
like how you want to binge it this show
would actually I can see why somebody
would want to do that but
selfishly the like whole binging
something where it takes you forever to
do it and then it comes out and it's
like all over in a weekend like yep that
sucks so I like that it's spread out but
also I I'm very annoying about this show
because I tell everybody like but you
have to watch all eight it doesn't make
sense unless you watch all that yeah
because you think I don't see how
someone could because I've watched three
yeah and I have to know because I didn't
read the book and I have to know what's
going on and I'm not going to give
anything away but I need to know because
I do care about these people and I'm
invested so I don't think that's going
to be a problem I don't see anybody
watching three or four of these and
saying I think I'm good okay good I
really hope not because it's it will
make you cry well I am a very uh very
powerful person in the industry uh and
also physically yeah I heard earlier
with the TV incredible yeah yeah and
torso right wow massive arms milky white
fat hanging and pendulous fat swinging
from side to side
like swing dancers
um like German swings Lizzy you broke
our you destroyed what was I think a
good podcast
um sorry with that image uh but um thank
you so much for being here I hope we get
to do this again because I don't think I
actually answered a single one of your
questions I don't think we I think this
was it right yeah I don't think you
asked any I don't yeah
it's just a nice talk I think it's on I
mean I have a whole bunch of questions
here but it's all about your finances oh
yeah I'd love to talk about my finances
okay because I see a real discrepancy in
your income tax return from two years
ago I know a full background betting
before any guests can come in your
solvent but we're worried that's a whole
other podcast they do want to do with
certain kinds of celebrities we are not
sure how they pay the rent and I wanted
break I want to say like no no seriously
tell me so wait a minute because you
haven't made movie in like seven years
but wait a minute so how and then
they'll be telling me no no I get this
much from Cameo and then I do this and
then I and I'll say yeah but okay but
you just pulled up in this car I know
but it's a lease
and I'm not gonna really pay it it's a
good idea and also they just have to go
on that celebrity net worth thing that
says everybody's worth like a hundred
million dollars yes like it's crazy that
means crazy yeah yeah no it's it's
anyone who's worked for more than three
years in a row 100 million 100 million
yeah yeah and then other people just
cite it like you know yeah that's how
that's but I think that's probably the
answer to your question of how these
people haven't worked it who haven't
made a movie in seven years they just
say look at celebrity net worth I have a
hundred million dollars
counts celebrity net worth is never
wrong and what if the IRS could use that
yeah that'd be really funny well
according to celebrity net worth
uos 25 million dollars I'm sure it's
used in like divorce proceedings oh yeah
you would think you should be able to
use it to get a loan for sure yeah oh
collateral yes yeah I'm gonna do that
today a lot of good a lot of good ideas
see coming out of this see yeah yeah
yeah and you thought this was going to
be off I thought it was going to be the
worst day of my life
turns out Lizzy Kaplan I salute you go
forth continue to do well and let's grab
a Guinness soon and when I say a
Guinness you know I mean six good night
[Laughter]